Digamos que tenemos la ecuación "7x" igual a 14, ok,
7 por "x" es igual a 14.
Ahora, antes de tratar de resolver esta ecuación,
yo quiero que pensemos un poco acerca
de lo que esto significa, ok.
Tal cual, lo que esta ecuación dice es que 7 veces "x"
es igual a 14, a ver,
7 veces la "x"...
la ponemos en rosa... es igual a 14.
Ahora estoy segura de que tú podrías resolver
esta ecuación en tu cabeza muy rápidamente,
es super natural tratar de sustituir el "x"
por número sencillos y ver si eso funciona,
o sea por ejemplo podríamos ver si funciona
cuando "x" es igual a 1
y entonces vemos si 7 veces un 1, que es lo mismo que 7 por 1 es igual a 14...
¡Ah! pues con el 1 no funcionó, entonces vamos en el siguiente número más sencillo,
o sea vamos con un 2 y vemos si 7 veces 2 o sea 7 por 2... mmm... 7 por 2 es igual a 14,
entonces aquí esta "x" de aquí, podemos decir rápidamente que es un 2.
Y hay muchas ecuaciones que son así de sencillas
y que se pueden resolver de esta forma,
sin embargo lo que vamos a hacer en este video,
es tratar de resolver estas ecuaciones de
una forma sistemática, para que cuando veas una ecuación mucho más complicada,
que sea muy muy difícil de resolver de esta forma,
entonces sepas muy bien cómo resolverla, ok.
Porque si hay ecuaciones muy complicadas que
están en chinas de resolver de esta forma
y estoy segura que eventualmente te vas a encontrar con algunas de ellas, de hecho con muchas de ellas.
Entonces es muy importante que aprendas a
manipular las ecuaciones, a transformarlas,
pero también es super importante que sepas
exactamente qué es lo que nos quieren decir,
qué es lo que significan todos estos símbolos.
Aquí tal vez debería de escribir un "por", 7 por "x".
Ahora, ¿por qué no estoy poniendo el símbolo de por o algo por el estilo, como lo hacíamos en aritmética?
Pues porque ahora estamos en álgebra y en álgebra ya no ponemos ese símbolo,
en álgebra tenemos estas variables y la variable más
común es una "x"
que es demasiado parecida al símbolo de por, ok.
Esta ecuación tal cual lo que significa es 7 por "x" es igual a 14, pero este símbolo resulta ser muy confuso
porque se parece demasiado a la "x", o sea aquí podría alguien pensar que estoy poniendo
"7xx" ó podrían pensar que estoy poniendo 7 por por y no saben por qué estoy multiplicando.
Entonces para la álgebra, este símbolo más
que ayudarnos nos estorba.
Ahora, hay otro símbolo para denotar que estamos multiplicando estas dos cosas, que también
se usa a veces, que es simplemente un puntito,
ok, ponemos aquí, 7, nuestro puntito de por
"x" igual a 14, estas tres ecuaciones son la misma cosa exactamente, pero como que en
general no se usa en álgebra, en general simplemente ponemos "7x" igual a 14
y todo el mundo sabe que eso significa que este 7
está multiplicando a esta variable.
Ahora, para aprender cómo manipular estas ecuaciones, lo primero que vamos a hacer es visualizar,
¿qué es lo que quiere decir esta ecuación?.
Así es que voy a reescribir esta ecuación,
pero de una forma más visual, ok.
A ver, aquí tenemos "7x", o sea 7 por "x"
y lo que nos dice la definición de multiplicación,
es que si aquí tenemos 7 por "x", lo que
realmente tenemos es "x" más "x" más "x",
o sea estamos sumando 7 veces "x", eso es
simplemente la definición de multiplicación.
Entonces "x" más "x", más "x", más "x",
más "x," más "x"...
a ver, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Y de este lado tenemos que esta suma de "7x"
o sea, 7 por "x", es igual a 14,
ahora este 14 también lo queremos en su forma visual, entonces lo que vamos a hacer es poner 14 cosas...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 ,13,
14... ¡bien!
Ok. Entonces estas dos ecuaciones, nos dicen exactamente lo mismo, son equivalentes.
Ahora, la razón por la que escribí esta
ecuación por acá, es para que entiendas
perfectamente, qué es lo que vamos a estar
haciendo cuando dividamos entre 7.
A ver, entonces, siempre que tenemos una ecuación
de esta forma, donde tenemos un número que
está multiplicando nuestra variable, generalmente
a este número se le llama coeficiente,
pero bueno, el chiste es que tenemos un número multiplicando a la variable igual a otro número
para encontrar a "x", o sea, para resolver esta ecuación ya nada más nos falta un solo paso
ok, y ese paso es dividir de los dos lados del igual,
entre el coeficiente de nuestra variable,
o sea, entre 7 en este caso.
Ok, entonces dividimos del lado izquierdo
entre 7 y entonces a fuerzas,
tenemos que dividir del lado derecho
entre 7 también, ok.
Porque este signo de igual lo que nos dice,
es que esta cosa es igual a esta otra cosa
y si queremos preservar este signo de igual,
si queremos que el lado izquierdo siga siendo
igual al lado derecho, entonces todo lo que
le hagamos al lado izquierdo,
se lo tenemos que hacer al lado derecho también.
Entonces si queremos dividir a "7x" entre 7, tenemos a fuerzas que dividir a 14 entre 7,
para que esto siga siendo igual a esto.
Entonces, lo que queremos es encontrar a "x"
y aquí "x" está multiplicándose por 7,
pero luego dividiéndose entre 7 y pues eso
es simplemente igual a "x",
porque multiplicar por 7 y luego dividir entre 7 es como no hacerle nada a esta "x".
Entonces este 7 se cancela con este 7 y nos
queda que "x" es igual a 14/7,
pero 14/7 es igual a 2.
Ahora, para entender exactamente qué es lo que estamos haciendo en el fondo, cuando dividimos
de los dos lados del igual entre 7, pues vamos a dividir visualmente los dos lados de esta ecuación
entre 7, ok, recuerda que esta ecuación es
equivalente a esta ecuación,
nada más la estamos escribiendo de
una  forma más visual
y bueno también vamos a hacer esta división
entre 7 de una forma más visual.
Ok, dividir este lado del igual entre 7 es exactamente igual a dividirlo en 7 pedazos iguales,
ok, este es el primer pedazo, segundo pedazo,
tercer pedazo, cuatro pedazos, cinco pedazos,
seis pedazos y siete pedazos y además
son todos igualitos.
Ahora, otra vez, si dividimos entre 7 de un un lado del igual, también tenemos que hacerlo
del otro lado del igual, para que sigan siendo
iguales, ok, entonces aquí vamos a dividir
esto en 7 partes iguales, 1 parte, 2 partes,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7 y listo,
acabamos de dividir cada uno de estos
lados en 7 partes iguales.
Ahora, si esta cosa completa era igual a esta cosa completa, porque tenía su símbolo de igual
y dividimos en 7 partes iguales, de los dos lados, entonces cada uno de estos pedacitos
va a ser igual a uno de los pedazos por acá, ok,  este pedazo es exactamente igual
a este pedazo y este otro pedazo va a ser exactamente igual a este otro pedazo, igual,
igual, este pedazo es igual a este pedazo, este otro
pedazo es igual a este pedazo
y así nos seguimos con todos los pedazos.
Y entonces lo que acabamos concluyendo, es
que cualquiera de los pedazos de acá,
o sea, por ejemplo, éste, que es una "x", que es igualito a todos los demás es igual a cualquiera
de los pedazos por acá, que son iguales y
que son además dos cositas.
Entonces, hemos concluido que "x" es igual
a 2, entonces vamos a hacer más ejemplos,
para que se quede muy grabado en tu cabeza
que estamos tratando con ecuaciones y que
a las ecuaciones las podemos manipular como
queramos, para encontrar a la "x", pero cualquier
cosa que le hagamos a un lado del igual, se
lo tenemos que hacer al otro lado también.
Ok, para hacer más ejercicios vamos a necesitar
más espacio así es que,
déjame subo esto un poco...
y ahora vamos a resolver "3x" igual a 15.
Ahora, otra vez, estoy segura de que puedes resolver esta ecuación en tu cabeza,
sustituyendo números hasta que llegues a
la respuesta correcta,
pero es muy importante poder resolver esta ecuación de una forma sistemática, ok.
Aquí el chiste es transformar esta ecuación,
hasta que nos queda la "x" solita,
ok, queremos deshacernos de este 3.
Y bueno, para hacer eso podemos dividir entre 3,
¿y por qué queremos dividir entre 3?
pues porque multiplicar por 3 y después dividir
entre 3, es como no hacerle nada a la "x".
Ahora, es muy importante recordar que estamos
en una ecuación y entonces si tenemos que
"3x" es igual a 15 y quiero dividir de este
lado entre 3 para poder seguir poniendo este
símbolo de igual y que tengamos todavía
una ecuación, lo que tengo que hacer es dividir
el lado derecho también entre 3, ok.
Y ahora sí, esta cosa sí sigue siendo igual
a esta cosa de acá.
Bueno y entonces aquí lo que tenemos
es que 3 por "x" entre "x",
los 3 se cancelan y nos queda simplemente una
"x" igual a 15 entre 3, un 5.
¡Y listo!
"x" es igual a 5.
Ahora, esta no es la única forma de resolver
esta ecuación, entonces vamos a ver otra
forma, tenemos aquí "3x" igual a 15 y tú
me puedes decir, "¡Ey Sal!
yo conozco otra forma de deshacerme de ese
3, porque no multiplicas por 1 entre 3
de los dos lados de la ecuación", ok, entonces
como estamos multiplicando por lo mismo
de los dos lados de la ecuación, entonces este
lado sigue siendo igual a este lado.
Y entonces si tomamos estos dos números y
los multiplicamos pues tenemos 1/3 por 3,
de eso lo que nos queda es 3 entre 3, que
es igual a 1 y esto está multiplicando a "x"
y es igual a 15 por 1/3, pero 15 por 1/3 es igual a 5, ok, entonces aunque aquí la "x" no se vea
completamente solita, ya está solita porque resulta que 1 por "x" es exactamente igual a "x".
Así es que listo, tenemos que "x" es igual a 5.
Y bueno, resulta que al multiplicar por 1/3 es exactamente equivalente a dividir entre 3.
Ahora vamos a resolver una ecuación ligeramente
más complicada.
Ok, vamos a ve "2y" más "4y" igual a 18,
ok, entonces para empezar, la variable ya
no es "x", ahora es una "y" y segundo, si
queremos sustituir por ejemplo "y" igual a
2, para ver si "y" igual a 2 es la respuesta
correcta, resulta que está un poco más difícil,
no, o sea tenemos 2 por 2 igual a 4, más
4 por 2 igual a 8, 8 más 4 = 12...
mmm...12 no es igual a 18 entonces "y" igual
a 2 no es la respuesta correcta,
pero si te fijas ya nos tardamos un poco más ¿no?,
o sea ahorita sustituyendo valores de "y"
está un poco más complicado ver cuál es la
respuesta ¿no?, pero bueno, entonces lo que
vamos a hacer, es ver qué es lo que nos esta
diciendo esta ecuación, aquí tenemos "2y"
y eso lo que significa es que estamos a una
"y" sumándole otra "y"
y después aquí tenemos más "4y", o sea que tenemos que sumar otras cuatro "y"...
1, 2, 3 y 4...
y eso, todo esto es igual a 18...
es igual a 18.
Ahora, ¿cuántas "y" tengo por acá?
Pues tengo, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 "y", ok, aquí todo esto, como estamos sumando seis "y",
esto es igual a 6 por "y", ok.
Entonces esta ecuación lo que es, "6y" es igual a 18...
"6y" es igual a 18.
Lo cual tiene todo el sentido del mundo ¿no?
o sea porque aquí tenemos "2y" más "4y"
y 2 más 4 es 6, ok, o sea, si tenemos 2 manzanas
y le sumamos 4 manzanas, pues eso lo que nos
queda, es simplemente 6 manzanas.
Y lo mismo pasa con las variables, ok, "2y"
más "4y" es igual a "6y".
Y ahora, con un poco de suerte, ya sabemos
exactamente cómo resolver estas ecuaciones,
aquí lo que hacemos es dividir de los dos
lados del igual entre el coeficiente de nuestra
variable "y" y entonces este 6 se cancela
con este 6 y nos queda que "y" es igual a
18 entre 6... es igual a 3.
Y lo padre de las ecuaciones es que siempre
podemos checar que la respuesta que nosotros
estamos dando sea correcta, ok, entonces aquí
podemos checar que "y" en efecto sí es igual
a 3, sustituyendo "y" por 3 en nuestra ecuación
original ok, entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es fijarnos en la ecuación y en cada lugar
que veamos una "y" vamos a poner un 3
y si lo que nos queda, sí es igual a 18, eso está comprobando que "y" en efecto tiene que ser igual a 3.
Entonces tenemos por aquí, 2 por 3...
3... más 4 por 3, ok, 2 por 3 es 6 más 4 por 3 es 12
y 6 más 12, en efecto sí es igual a 18,
entonces ya verificamos que "y"
sí tiene que ser igual a 3 y listo.